of Ryan who Darren Aronofsky filmed some
light-hearted holiday Christmas cheer
[Music]
so the whales directed by Darren
Aronofsky Stars Brendan Fraser was
written by Samuel D Hunter who wrote the
play this film is based off of he's
credited for writing the film I don't
know if he actually wrote a new
screenplay for the film or if Aronofsky
just took the script and was like yeah
that works this is a script for our
movie The Script for the play because
there are clips on YouTube of scenes
from the play and I'm like that is
verbatim the film The film's about a man
named Charlie who internet says the
character is 600 pounds I don't know if
they actually give a weight in the film
point is he's given a very Grim
prognosis from his friend who's a nurse
so we decide to try to reconnect with
his estranged daughter played by Sadie
Singh which it doesn't surprise me that
Darren Aronofsky took this on you look
at the wrestler the wrestler is about an
estranged father and daughter and then
the estranged father tries to reconnect
with his daughter after he's given a
very serious medical prognosis the whale
is about an estranged father and
daughter and the father tries to
reconnect with the daughter after he's
given a very serious medical prognosis
and let's get it out of the way first
let's just do it let's talk about
Brandon Fraser because we we heard he
crushes it in this film we heard he is a
shoe-in for an Oscar nomination I do
slightly disagree I think he's a shoe in
for an Oscar win I need to know that I
one thing right was my life but you can
say that about Darren Aronofsky films in
general the dude knows how to pull
performances every one of his films like
Noah's the least Aronofsky film of all
of them so if you want to leave that one
out sure but you look at every other
film he's ever done there's a
performance in each of those films where
you're like that's incredible if I were
in Vegas I I'd put my bets on Brendan
Fraser winning for all you good folks
who lost money on that Patty the Baddie
fight here's your Mulligan don't take my
word for it I'm not giving you gambling
advice don't do that don't take that I
talk about movies on YouTube for a
living don't listen to me I'm just
saying I would make that bet fair in
Vegas can you bet on the Oscars in Vegas
he is incredible in this film if you had
an actor who did less than the work he
does the film really wouldn't work as
well as it does seems like it yeah no
[ __ ] kind of statement but the cast is
very small one main actor Brendan Fraser
for supporting actors and that's it
five supporting actors including Dan the
pizza guy but I'm telling you it's a
very intimate film and one of the things
that helps is the fact that you never
see the fat suit makeup when you're
seeing Brendan Fraser's character I've
seen that on TV other movies you see the
fat suit you see the makeup it just kind
of takes you out of it that's another
Oscar this film might be up for best
makeup because it was an incredible job
well done and seeing Brendan Fraser give
us a performance like this is something
special maybe 20 years ago or so he
wasn't in the place to pull from that
much pain but I see his talent as
it's like a treasure like Berry gold and
imagine someone panning for gold and
they get a few nuggets and they're like
oh great that's enough looks like it's
tapped but then two feet down or 20
years later however you want to see it
there's this huge gold deposit the size
of Fort Knox
that's Brandon Fraser's Talent we didn't
know it was there we thought we'd seen
it all we thought we'd gotten it all he
had much more to give now the film in
terms of tone is very man
um dark yes but the clusterphobic as
well it makes sense that it's based off
of a play because you're hanging out
with this guy in his living room for 99
of the film you look at cost effective
stage plays they usually have that one
location that the story takes place in
so your watches you're like oh yeah this
is totally based off of a stage play and
that intimate if not claustrophobic
feeling is aided by the 4x3 aspect ratio
presentation now this film is decidedly
Darren Aronofsky and for for my part
that excites me it's like Darren
Aronofsky Quentin Tarantino Christopher
Nolan James Cameron these are all
directors that when they come out with
something new it feels like an event to
me I can only describe it as like it's
game day and your favorite team is
playing you just have to watch it right
now you don't want to wait for TiVo you
don't want to record it watch it later
you need to watch it right now people
still record stuff or is it just on
demand now is that what it's called
whatever you can't wait to pop in the
VHS and watch it later after you adjust
the tracking there I said it but also
this being a Darren Aronofsky film I can
say this phrase this is not for
everybody and I'll be right I can say
that about every Aronofsky film before
and every Darren Aronofsky film he does
from now until the end of his career
until he retires now this film is not
going to be for everybody I've already
seen chatter online where some people
find it problematic but I myself I found
something very special in here I found a
very heartfelt story about pain loss
human connection family connection
everybody in this film has at least a
moment where they just come across as a
little rough around the edges some more
than others even the super likable
people have a couple of moments of
dialogue where it's like you're kind of
being high and mighty right now but the
film also gives context to pain so you
see both sides of it you see how they
are you see why they are the way they
are that's the real magic right there
that's the mythical element because
that's a luxury we are rarely afforded
in life with the people we actually
interact with but everyone in this film
is dealing with something because
everyone in life always is that's just
life I feel like this is one of those
films you're going to be in one of two
camps and that's it it's either
uncomfortably unenjoyable or you're
gonna find something special with it
I think there's a lot of room for in
between for some I feel like Brandon
Fraser's performance might be the reason
to go see it even if you don't generally
enjoy the film but that's absolutely
fair for some folks out there a
Powerhouse performance is enough but
honestly it's not just Brendan Fraser I
mean what he gives us is truly something
special absolutely but Hong Chow in the
movie has a couple of scenes where she
is bringing it I feel like she's in the
conversation for the Oscar as well or
should be this is a film with layers and
that's something special when I come out
of the movie theaters usually you watch
a movie and well that's what the movie
is and that's what you take home and I
word vomit on camera and there you are
this is a film I feel like I can peel
back over time and enjoy the process of
doing so so I myself I buy all of Darren
aronofsky's films I say that because yes
I feel this film is worth watching and
worth buying on Blu-ray like I'm the guy
I I can watch Requiem for a Dream every
Friday like I've said before in my
videos in fact I might I might actually
watch it that's right while you're
watching a Christmas story I'll I'll be
watching Requiem for a Dream
Merry Christmas all right so the whale
have you seen it what did you think
about it what's your favorite Darren
Aronofsky film whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]